una advertencia aterrador a los cinco
glaciares alpinos de alemania podrían
desaparecer en los próximos quince años
y la mayoría de los glaciares de los
alpes desaparecerán en los próximos
cincuenta años pronosticó un glaciólogo
alemán esto porque se han derretido
drásticamente en los últimos años y han
perdido gran parte de su volumen en la
última década debido a las altas
temperaturas y las escasas
precipitaciones
entre mons y en principio toda esta
discusión se sostiene y cae con esto
porque la correlación entre el clima y
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero es tan clara que es la forma
más fácil de hacer ajustes allí
a más de 16.000 kilómetros de distancia
se encuentra fin donde las mujeres han
notado que la namá un tipo de alga
comestible que forma parte de su dieta
diaria y que es su principal fuente de
ingresos tarda cada vez más tiempo en
volver a crecer pues es muy sensible al
calor los informes de la agencia de
protección del medio ambiente de eeuu
indican que en los últimos 30 años la
temperatura de la superficie del mar ha
sido sistemáticamente más alta que en
cualquier otro momento afectando a los
ecosistemas marinos y provocando una
mayor pérdida de hábitat
es triste de verdad es triste porque
esto ha sido su forma de vida así que el
agotamiento del suministro de nama
significa realmente la ilusión de una
forma de vida y hasta cierto punto de la
cultura y las tradiciones
[Música]
entre tanto china declaró la alerta
amarilla en todo el país por la sequía
las temperaturas por encima de los 30
grados en casi todo el territorio han
dañado los cultivos y han limitado el
suministro de agua potable a algunas
comunidades rurales situaciones tan
distantes pero que evidencian que los
efectos adversos del cambio climático no
conocen fronteras